If Venom's success the first time around was
largely due to the elements of surprise and
strangeness, what could the second one have
up its sleeve?
A lot, potentially.
While the law of diminishing returns runs
rampant in Hollywood sequels, Venom 2 could
actually improve upon its predecessor.
Making Venom the center of his own franchise
presents Sony with some unique challenges
and possibilities.
After all, it's not very often that a comic
book character who's usually a villain or
an anti-hero becomes the protagonist of a
comic book franchise.
Luckily for Sony, Venom has a nemesis of his
own: Carnage.
Carnage entered the Marvel Universe in the
early '90s, when writer David Michelinie came
up with the idea of a symbiote stripped of
Venom's moral code.
Along with artist Erik Larsen, he introduced
Cletus Kasady, a deranged serial killer and
Eddie Brock's prison cellmate.
After coming into contact with some of Venom's
drippings, Kasady became Carnage, a blood-red
monster that's fought both Venom and Spider-Man
over the years.
Needless to say, Carnage creeping to the big
screen in Venom 2 will make for a wild ride.
Carnage's appearance in the Venom sequel was
promised by the movie's mid-credits sequence.
If you got up and left the theater as soon
as that Eminem song kicked in, you missed
a performance with the potential to match
Tom Hardy's in fearless weirdness.
Eddie Brock is sent to a prison to interview
notorious serial killer Cletus Kasady, played
by Woody Harrelson:
"When I get outta here, and I will, there's
gonna be carnage."
The Venom Blu-ray offered an extended version
of this scene, giving Harrelson a little extra
time to make an impression:
"Talk about sucking out their eyeballs.
Crunchy on the outside."
With Harrelson's history of going all-out
as mesmerizingly unstable characters in movies
like Natural Born Killers and Seven Psychopaths,
Harrelson's expanded role in Venom 2 promises
to push it even more over-the-top than its
predecessor.
Sony's plans to explore the dark corners of
Spider-Man's world go beyond Venom and Carnage.
In 2018, the studio made the somewhat left-field
announcement that Jared Leto would be starring
in Morbius.
For those unfamiliar, Morbius the Living Vampire
has been a Spider-Man supporting character
since the '70s, although he really came into
his own during the same '90s goth craze that
propelled Venom to stardom.
Very little is known about the plot of the
Morbius movie, but Sony is pretty much guaranteed
to link these two antiheroes in their effort
to keep up in the "Cinematic Universe" game.
The possible introduction of vampires into
Sony's Spider-Verse opens up some intriguing
new supernatural doorways for Venom 2, even
if Eddie Brock can't hold a candle to our
favorite vampire hunter:
"You give Frost a message for me.
You tell him it's open season on all suckheads."
We know that a Venom sequel is coming, and
that Tom Hardy and Woody Harrelson are contracted
to star, but that's really all we know for
certain.
Jeff Pinkner, co-writer of the first movie,
couldn't confirm any more than that in a recent
interview with the Discussing Film YouTube
channel.
"I can't say anything other than that it is
happening."
"Okay, it's happening.
Are you writing it?"
"I am not."
But while that was all the writer could say
with certainty, he did drop one other major
statement
“It is not impossible that in a future or
upcoming Venom movie that Spider-Man will
play a significant role."
With Sony's rapidly expanding Spider-Verse,
a potential cameo by the webhead could take
many forms.
Maybe Tom Holland's MCU Peter Parker would
swing by, or perhaps another alternate universe
incarnation would be the foil to Hardy's Eddie
Brock.
Regardless, a crossover would be sure to get
fans' senses tingling.
Superhero origins can be complicated.
That's why comics history is so full of reboots,
retcons, and reimaginings.
It's also why the plot of the Venom movie
was sometimes messy.
Take a look at most reviews, and you'll find
that the story structure is one of the most
commonly criticized elements.
Sometimes, superhero sequels are stronger
than their predecessors.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier outshone
The First Avenger, Thor: Ragnarok proved that
the third time can be the charm, and The Dark
Knight unquestionably topped Batman Begins.
Done right, Venom 2 has the perfect opportunity
to address the first movie's biggest issues.
Even the negative reviews of Venom tended
to dish out some positive comments about Tom
Hardy's bizarre dual performance as Eddie
Brock and Venom.
It's no surprise that Venom appealed to a
performer as adventurous as Tom Hardy.
After all, the job required him to tackle
the primal acting challenge of performing
two-person dialogues with himself.
In fact, he may have had a little too much
fun to fit in the movie, as he revealed during
the press junket that much of his favorite
material didn't make the final cut.
“There are about 30 or 40 minutes worth
of scenes that aren't in this movie."
"Those are your favorites, right?"
"All of them, yeah."
Although trimming down a film's more indulgent
passages is a normal part of the filmmaking
process, it's hard not to wonder how entertaining
all those scenes of Hardy enjoying himself
would be.
Now that it's clear what a strong asset his
eccentric choices were in the first movie,
maybe the sequel will give him even more room
to play.
"And I have proof!"
In his review for That Shelf, critic Victor
Shiff said,
"Venom feels like several competing films
— a Jekyll and Hyde story, an odd couple
movie, a broad comedy — stitched together
into one incoherent mess."
It's hard to completely disagree.
Gritty violence, emotional melodrama, and
wacky sci-fi goofs are all held together within
the movie's gooey structure.
Even when the individual elements make for
a fun ride, it sometimes feels like a movie
that isn't quite sure what kind of total picture
it's going for.
Of course, some of that tonal dissonance could
be considered an accurate reflection of Eddie
Brock's splitting psyche as he adjusts to
the idea of playing host to an alien entity.
And let's not forget that it's basically a
Spider-Man movie without Spider-Man, a pitch
so odd that some uncertainty on the part of
the filmmakers is understandable.
Now, though, the creators of the sequel can
look back at the finished product to build
a stronger foundation to support the next
chapter.
"Parasite?"
"It's a turn of endearment!"
"Apologize!"
"No."
"Alright, fine, I'm sorry."
Even during those early days of Venom hype
when no one knew quite what to expect, fans
always had a checklist of things their favorite
symbiote's big adventure should contain.
A movie about Venom should be dark, it could
definitely get violent, it absolutely must
get weird, and it could potentially even get
a little kinky.
There was a certain amount of disappointment,
then, when the MPAA slapped the finished product
with a crowd-friendly PG-13.
Now that Venom has proven successful enough
to get a sequel, Sony might also consider
it worth investing in a more niche film.
Even if Venom 2 is another PG-13 outing, more
intense footage could be saved for an alternate
home video cut.
Like it or not, fans romantically shipping
Eddie Brock and Venom was inevitable.
It's no surprise that a movie as bizarre and
meme-worthy as Venom would inspire fans to
spend way too much time thinking about the
bond between its two intertwined main characters.
Whether you see it as an interstellar buddy
movie, a strangely star-crossed rom-com, or
a very particular kind of fetish story, it's
undeniable that much of Venom's charm is in
the interplay between a boy and his blob.
"I am putting my hands up."
"You are making us look bad."
“No I am not!"
"Yes you are!"
"No I'm not!"
Of course, it took a long time for these two
to become one.
Much of the movie was dedicated to introducing
Eddie, setting up the symbiote's arrival on
Earth, contriving their accidental encounter,
and running them through the trials of their
partnership.
It wasn't until the story neared its climax
that they really started working together,
finally blossoming into the weird little family
they were meant to be.
The sequel can take their relationship to
new levels… maybe even some weird levels.
"Like a turd in the wind.
Do you feel me?"
"What the hell are you?"
"We are Venom."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Marvel
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.